So we had our panel discussion on the
stifling of free speech and university
campuses November 11 with doctor sad and
doctor Mfa and it was a capacity crowd,
1500 it was sold out and there was people
that came from all over Canada and the
u s even some people from Europe.
Surprisingly.
And I guess you and I chatted about this
before that I was really surprised at
the absolute lack of any mainstream
media coverage of an issue that is very
important for our times and the fact that
it was the largest such event held in
Canada.
So I'm surprised about it,
but you didn't seem so surprised about it.
Why is that?
Well,
but not really surprised,
I would say at the moment
by anything that happens,
let's say in that conventional media.
Um,
I think that what's happened to
large degree is that the people,
the journalists who operate in that
sphere have started confusing themselves
with the newsmakers themselves.
And so they feel in some sense like
they should be leading the narrative,
let's say instead of saying we get,
and so if an event occurs,
that's outside of what they assume.
I mean,
we're painting this with a broad brush
because there's obviously journalists who
don't fit into this category.
Um,
but if it doesn't fall under their
fall under the guidelines
of their a priori story,
then it isn't news.
And all that's happening as
a consequence of that though,
I think Serena,
is that they're the mainstream media,
so to speak,
is dooming itself to irrelevancy
at an unbelievably rapid rate.
See that with,
uh,
certainly,
um,
American news newspapers,
which are now being replaced because
people are tuning into social media to get
their news.
Uh,
and a lot of people say they don't even
actually trust mainstream journalists
anymore,
which is a sad statement because media
is such an important aspect of any
democratic society.
Yeah.
Well,
it's become democratized in a big way.
And so maybe this is for the best,
it's hard to say.
Um,
there'll be pros and cons.
I mean,
I've had,
I can't complain about my treatment at
the hands of the media over the last year
in general,
though,
I mean,
there's been a lot of like post media,
the entire post media group of about 250
newspapers came out in support of what
I was doing and Margaret went to and
Christie Blatchford and Conrad Black and
are two,
so em to Nela and a whole array of,
of journalists have been
very forceful advocates,
I would say for free speech.
So we also want to keep that in mind,
right?
Absolutely.